Good Morning John
I wanna make a really complicated video today.
Something that was just like awesome and epic
But I just .. I just don't have time.
And it's even not because I'm busy
It's just like ..
That was fun
Story behind that..
..uh.. There's a channel..
..on YouTube called AVBYTE
When I was talking about how obssessed I am with Instagram
Somebody linked me to their Instagram Musical
And then I loved it. And then ..
.. I loved everything else that they've done
A new musical .. On YouTube.. Every week
How amazing is that!
So yeah, I emailed them and I was like
.. we should do one about Tumblr and I should be in it
We wrote the lyrics together
They did the music
We did the video
It was not... It was a long process
Not kidding
74 emails were exchanged in the preparation of this
That's a lot
I hope you enjoyed it
So then the next couple of weeks are gonna be kinda intense for me
Going on tour with Harry and the Potters very briefly
Again, Oregon and Washington people
If you wanna come see us play there's dates in the dooblydoo
And then I get a couple days back in Missoula
And then i"m going to Leekycon
And during that time
It's sort of like the rush up to the landing of the Mars Science Laboratory
Which is .. just a really intense for me
I just made a video about it
It's gonna go live on SciShow this weekend and ..
I'm so scared
and excited
It's just, oof..
I should do a musical about that
Oh also. John thanks for talking about my buffness
So now everybody wants to like see me with my shirt off
which would be a tremendously unimpressive experience for everyone
I promise
Hope you liked the song
It's not on iTunes yet
But it will be shortly
I'll tweet that and
Of course I'll put it on my Tumblr
And if you haven't experienced Tumblr
It is a weird
but very fun place
Try not to spend your whole life there
Go do other things
Outside things even
with your computer though
Bring your computer
And spin around in circles
Like that. That's nice
Good
John, I'm excited to see you at Leakycon but first
I will see you on Monday
Oh my God
This is way hotter than the last time I was on this dish